this is a pie chart and this is Scottish
political Economist William Playfair who
created the world's first pie chart
along with some of the first line and
bar charts data visualization is
everywhere today but when Playfair first
created them over 200 years ago using
shapes to represent numbers was largely
snared at
how could drawings truly represent solid
scientific data but now data
visualization has become an art form of
its own here are five charts that have
in their own way changed the world
one of the best known uses of data
visualization was devised in London in
at the time it was widely believed that
infectious diseases like cholera were
spread through the air surgeon Jon Snow
felt differently he was convinced that
infections could be spread by dirty
water and when a deadly outbreak of
Cholera occurred in SoHo snow tracked
each case and marked them with a DOT on
a map
a clear picture emerged all the deaths
from cholera were clustered around a
water pump on Broad Street
when he presented his findings to the
local officials the pump was shut down
and the outbreak ended
Dr Jon Snow fundamentally changed our
understanding of microbes and his simple
dot Maps were a huge part of that
around about the same time the lady with
a lamp Florence Nightingale used a
cunning visual to save even more lives
during the Crimean War she realized that
unsanitary conditions in hospitals were
killing more soldiers than were dying on
the battlefield itself she wanted to
persuade Queen Victoria head of the
British army at the time to fund better
conditions in military hospitals so she
created the coxcomb a sort of uneven pie
chart which showcased the data on the
causes of soldiers deaths in a highly
effective way
her efforts had sweeping impact not only
improving the sanitary conditions of
army hospitals at the time but
ultimately changing the face of Modern
Health Care
one of the most original examples of
data visualization was created by
American historian and civil rights
activist W.E.B Du Bois for the 1900
Paris World's Fair he presented a series
of handmade charts showcasing the
educational social and business
accomplishments of black Americans in
the 35 years since slavery had been
officially abolished the materials both
challenge stereotypes and Illustrated
how black communities were still being
discriminated against
Du Bois hoped the visualizations would
help to end racial Prejudice in the
world the problem of the 20th century is
the problem of the color line he wrote
although his dreams weren't realized the
boy's beautiful charts are now
recognized as a powerful use of data
visualization to demonstrate social
change
[Music]
data visualization can also be used for
misinformation sometimes with disastrous
consequences
this is the kalakak family tree
as a chart it's not groundbreaking but
its impact was profound
it was conjured up by Henry Goddard an
American psychologist and eugenicist who
believed that one of society's greatest
problems was feeble-minded people
basically anyone deemed to be of lower
intelligence Goddard wrote a book based
on the story of Martin kalakak a soldier
who was married and had a family of fine
upstanding citizens
but according to the book Martin kalakak
had a one-night stand with a
feeble-minded barmaid
she had a son who became known as old
horror who went on to Father 10 children
according to Goddard feeble-mindedness
was hereditary and the family was full
of what he called the lowest types of
human beings
but it was a fiction the barmaid never
existed even so the kalakak family tree
could be found in school textbooks as
late as the 1950s and it was also used
by the Eugenics movement for decades
afterwards
and it was adopted by the Nazis who used
it in propaganda films to gain support
for their racial Purity laws which led
to the murder of thousands of disabled
people in the Holocaust
sometimes iconic status can be achieved
almost accidentally in 2018 scientist Ed
Hawkins was invited to give a speech
about climate change at hay a literary
Festival in Wales he needed to convey
the increase in global average
temperatures to a largely non-scientific
audience so he devised a chart that used
no words just colors it was a stunningly
simple way of demonstrating how the
planet had warmed since 1850. the chart
known as the warming Stripes uses Blues
to indicate cooler than average years
and reds to show years with temperatures
hotter than average
updated every year Hawkins says 2022 was
the first year that every country needed
a new red stripe demonstrating how fast
the earth's climate is changing although
the graphic breaks some of the rules of
data visualization it doesn't provide a
title or Legend arguably it is one of
the most iconic Graphics of modern times
what do you think the next chart to
change the world will be
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video